ein schlechter verlierer donald trump
wie denkst du würde erst aufnehmen wenn
das jetzt tatsächlich so ausgeht wie die
zahlen ist gerade verlauten lassen dass
joe biden der nächste präsident der
vereinigten staaten wird die amerikaner
sagen hier das wäre dann das
seasonfinale in dieser welle die tv show
namens trump präsidentschaft und man hat
es ja schon gesehen
der amerikanische präsident habe
offensichtlich nicht vor
hiermit würde abzutreten seine gestrige
pressekonferenz eine stellungnahme war
ja eindeutig dass er hier wirklich das
ganze die ganze amerikanische demokrat
demokratie hier offensichtlich mitnehmen
möchte raus aus dem weißen haus
wirklich abtreten das wird ein
wirkliches drama werden und optimiert
darüber aber auch hat aber auch angst
davor wie viel schaden jetzt noch
angerichtet werden kann
durch einen präsidenten der die
niederlage einfach nicht anerkennen
möchte der vor dem gericht zieht
wie lange haben wie intensiv das noch
betreiben möchte wird man jetzt sehen
aber die anzeichen stehen jedenfalls auf
sturm und amerika ist teilweise
natürlich auch ein wenig amüsiert aber
insgesamt doch sehr beunruhigt über
diese entwicklung
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bet schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren